To answer this question we need to know the number of
users who did check in using mobile and the total number of
users in our sample. Now I could have just used these two
numbers and divided them, but I want to do this programmatically. To
do that I can take the sum of my mobile check
in variables when it's equal to one. And then divide that by
the length of that vector. This is how many users are in
our sample. Running that code I can see that I get about
64.5%, or 64.6%. Rounding to the nearest percent, that's just
65. Now that's over half of the users in the data
set, so it wouldn't make a whole lot of sense
to continue the development of the mobile experience. At least based
on this sample data set. So when you're answering questions,
it's important not to just think about what kind of data
you're looking at but maybe what types of transformations you can
make to the variables themselves. Sometimes you want raw counts, and
other times you just want a binary yes or no, did a
user use this. It's important to think about what kind of data you
need to answer a specific question. So not every sort of transformation
you do has to be a functional transformation like square root or log.